J'avais comme une douleur de couteau à la
poitrine
avant d'aller à l'hôpital et
que je n'avais jamais ressentie auparavant
[Music] [
Music]
J'avais travaillé cinq quarts de suite consécutifs
nous avions vu plusieurs
patients suspects de coronavirus entre cinq et six
marcher sur le quart de travail, puis lentement arriver
et ils monteraient
aux soins intensifs, donc c'était une
présentation continue de patients monovirus qui
étaient aux urgences à tout moment à ce
moment-là, il est dix heures du soir
samedi, je suis  avoir de plus en plus de
fièvres subjectives douleurs généralisées douleurs à la
poitrine douleurs au dos et j'ai
du mal à respirer j'ai du mal à
marcher juste pour aller aux toilettes je suis très
essoufflé je suis incapable de finir mes
phrases mon mari dit d'accord je'  J'en ai
assez tu sais que je t'emmène à l'
hôpital où tu travailles pour te faire soigner
le matin du jeudi 19 mars étant
que je travaille à domicile je me suis levé assis devant mon
ordinateur la pression thoracique était un peu
plus intense et c'était '  Je ne pars pas
assis et je travaille donc c'était le
premier jour où j'étais comme si j'avais entendu certaines choses,
quelque chose ne va pas, mais en regardant les nouvelles
et en entendant tout sur New
York, je suis à Manhattan à New York, il
manque de tests et d'EPI  et
à moins que vous ne soyez vraiment désespéré, nous devons
enregistrer ces tests et EPI pour les premiers
intervenants ou les personnes qui en ont vraiment besoin,
alors j'ai pris une décision ce jour-là, je
vais juste rester à la maison, je vais m'en
sortir et je vais juste  surveiller mes symptômes
probablement vers 20h00.  Dimanche soir, j'ai
commencé à avoir des quintes de toux et chaque
fois que je terminais une crise de toux,
je
ne pouvais pas reprendre mon souffle et à ce
moment-là, j'étais comme quelque chose à nouveau, votre
corps vous dit que quelque chose ne va pas
et je viens juste plus tard cette nuit-là, je
J'allais vers minuit, j'étais tellement
mal à l'aise, j'étais tellement paniqué
que j'étais comme si d'accord, laissez-moi, laissez-moi
appeler une ambulance et me rendre à l'hôpital
parce que quelque chose ne va pas, l'adolescent wop
par moi-même pour me vérifier à nouveau et a été
immédiatement vu par mon co  -les travailleurs et mon
médecin à ce moment-là, j'ai littéralement eu une
dépression émotionnelle, toute la force
que j'avais utilisée pour m'empêcher
de m'effondrer était partie.
J'ai éclaté en sanglots.  était
complètement vaincu je me sentais comme un
échec total pour m'être exposé à
cet environnement pour avoir contracté
la maladie et maintenant je suis tu sais
potentiellement le partager avec ma famille mes
collègues j'étais dévasté j'avais peur
parce que je ne savais pas exactement  à quoi
m'attendre de plus j'aime juste que j'étais assis
à l'hôpital quand vous avez des enfants
n'avez pas de famille pas d'amis donc c'est comme si j'étais
très émotif et je pense que la
partie la plus effrayante est quand vous
traversez quelque chose comme ça vous vous
en le traversant seuls, ils m'ont dit qu'ils
manquaient d'EPI, donc la plupart du
temps, j'ai dit qu'ils ne pouvaient pas entrer
dans la chambre, alors ils m'ont appelé au
téléphone de l'hôpital que j'avais les
symptômes classiques que j'ai commencé avec le
fièvre la fièvre en trois jours est montée à
environ 102 j'ai eu un léger mal de gorge et
une très très très petite toux cependant j'ai
perdu 20 livres et 12 morceaux je n'ai pas perdu
de graisse c'est vraiment j'ai perdu beaucoup de muscle
mais un IV  sur moi parce que j'étais déshydraté,
je suppose qu'ils m'ont donné des médicaments pour les
maux de tête sévères et m'ont donné des médicaments
pour les nausées
tu vas mourir ce n'était pas une
expérience agréable surtout avec les étourdissements
tu penses juste que ça ne va jamais partir
c'est si long-  pendant que vous devriez euh
juste vous sentir mal, je vais être honnête avec
vous quand je faisais l'hôpital cette
nuit-là étant que j'avais du mal à
respirer et j'avais regardé suffisamment de nouvelles
à ce moment-là pour voir que beaucoup de
gens vont à l'hôpital  et s'ils
sont hospitalisés, cela peut être un
ralentissement soudain, vous pourriez vous retrouver sous
respirateur et si vous vouliez un
appareil respiratoire, vous pourriez même ne pas
y arriver et ce sont les pensées qui sont
devenues incontrôlables cette nuit-là pour
moi
[Musique]